Now at first glance,
reducing the payload
of each transfer,
and only transmitting data
when it's required
seems like a sound approach.
You're reducing the amount
of data being transferred,
so that's less data on the network.
That's less superfluous
work being done
storing processing data
on the device.
It's basically a case
of putting off any work
until you actually know
you need to do it.
But it turns out that this
approach has it's drawbacks,
compared to the big cookie model
of doing all that work up front.
So, overall, this is
a better solution.
But let's take a closer look
at the big cookie model.
And to do that, we really
need to understand
the underlying
cell radio state machine.